in a multiverse of infinite
possibilities ring in 2018 with all
episodes of Hebrew buddy happy holidays
there's a whole bunch of Rick and Morty
that's getting ready to drop because
they're rerunning the season for New
Year's so they're probably gonna do a
couple of special promos there are a
couple videos that I've been sitting on
I have a gravity falls Easter Egg video
that I'm making so be sure to subscribe
to get that because it's the holidays
I'll do a new round of the merch
giveaway that I'll explain at the end of
the video but the really important stuff
is that one of the producers actually
did an interview for season 4 so I'll
air his clip then I'll explain what's
going on
so are you guys working on season 4
right now and if not when when does that
start no I'm actually I know one as far
as I know no one's working on the show
and I'm certainly not so I don't know
what's going on I haven't heard anything
and yeah they really take their time I
never understood why everybody all
parties D and Justin and adults and
didn't get their together make make
the show fast I just don't get it it
doesn't make any sense to me I'm sure
they all have their reasons but are you
saying there's a possibility there won't
be a season 4 or do you think there will
be I don't think there's a III I highly
doubt there won't be I just I'm shocked
as taken we got done writing season 3 in
November of last year and here we are 11
months later Wow
yeah so it you know and then and then
and then I know how long the show takes
the right let alone animate so it's just
like it I'd be surprised that there was
a fourth season on the air any sooner
than 2019 then late 2019 Wow yeah it's
crazy I just get your together you
guys get it all together put it in the
backpack too quick so the big thing
about that is he implies there might not
be Rick and Morty till 2019 but it kind
of flies in the face of some of the
things that Dan Harmon said during their
live stream before the season started
tonight what
plan to do is solve a lot of problems
like productively Justin and I we're
gonna figure out how to make season four
faster more efficient how we're gonna
open the hood on that creative process
and like you know help you help we're
gonna do it help ourselves like generate
Rick and wordy so much faster that
season four can premiere up to two hours
after season three yeah if there's a
season four right which there might be
speaking I mean who knows if we'll even
show up needle we might die attack
horrible accident
boat accident not to get too specific if
you don't remember that that was the
event that they used to drop the season
three trailer just promote the season
getting ready to start the reason why he
said all those things about them getting
their together is because it took
them just shy of two years of actual
production time to get season three out
so what happened is is around October
November 2015 they actually started
writing the episodes the writers room
met for the first time you can all see
them here around December having their
holiday dinner before they go on break
then in January they're back in the
writers room in by February they're
recording the first episode so it took
them a couple months to start recording
episodes and then by about July of 2016
they had started to record episode seven
so they're almost through with the
season but pretty much through the
entirety of 2016 they had been animating
episodes by the time they're ready to
record an episode they're usually
already in the process of animating
parts of it they had the pickle rig
animatic that they dropped at Comic Con
so that gives you an idea for how far
along in production they were although
they probably finished that a little bit
earlier it just decided to use that
because pickle rick was one of the
biggest episodes of the season the
writers were still in the writers room
as recently as this past august by about
the time they finished airing half of
the season so when Dan Harmon had said
that they completely re-engineered their
creative process the idea was is that
they'd already started to break ideas
for season four but everybody breaks for
the holidays so no one is working on
episodes right now as we speak most
people in Hollywood don't go back to
work till early January anyway the one
thing that's different about this year
is that the writers aren't talking to
each other on social media
quite as much as they were while they
were producing season three so like
while they were writing episodes during
2015 and 2016
they were just tweeting each other pages
like oh look I finished my script we're
recording it today so there's any work
that's actually been happening for
season four recently it's been very
preliminary in behind the scenes but
it's also possible that they're just
staying off of social media because it
was such a crazy reaction to everything
this year but like a couple of the
people on the staff are working on other
projects too justin roiland just
released a new video game through his
squatched endo label called accounting
plus so he's been doing a lot of work on
that Dan Harmon is doing the normal Dan
Harmon thing he does harmontown
all the time anyway but he also pitches
shows around town he's been complaining
about how he doesn't have any money he's
waiting for Rick and Morty checks to
come in he does that all the time so
it's not really a good benchmark for
where they are in production they've
been doing non-canonical promos like
where they killed the butter dish if you
remember that from earlier this year
[Music]
rest in peace butter dish so a lot of
them did say that they were out of work
recently but that just means that they
went on break for Rick and Morty and
they haven't come back to the writers
room yet because typically when writers
aren't actually writing on episodes and
when writers rooms break for a season
they go unemployed for a couple of
months until they either go on another
show or they come back to that writers
room to work on episodes again so before
all this new interview stuff my
assumption was that they were gonna try
and get season four out about the same
time that they released season 3 during
the summer next year if Dan Harmon is to
be believed and they are getting it out
faster than they got season 3 out which
took them a little less than two years
then even if they didn't get episodes
out to the beginning of 2019 he would
still be within the time frame that Dan
Harmon allotted like faster than season
3 but still a little bit longer
than you expected but as much of a
bummer is that sounds like the funny
thing is is that everybody has a
conspiracy theory about a special
Christmas episode that would give them
the opportunity to do an April Fool's
Day style Christmas Day episode but it
would just be Christmas 2018 not 2017
like a lot of people had hoped there
were a lot of people that thought there
might be a secret Christmas episode this
season which obviously has been blown
wide open because we're well past
Christmas there was no new episode so
just let me know in the comments when do
you think that they will actually get
season four out and do you think that
they'll actually fulfill their prophecy
of a Christmas special in 2018 that
would actually be pretty funny I don't
know that they actually planned it that
way I think they just assumed it would
take a long time so they were giving
themselves some wiggle room like don't
be surprised if it takes a long time to
get season four out but we should
actually get some more information by
the beginning of next year because no
matter how fast they work they would
absolutely have to start work by the
beginning of next year in order to get
episodes out by 2019 otherwise you're
looking at 2020 in another huge fan
revolt so no worries but if you have any
special requests for Rick and Morty
videos just leave them in the comments
below
what'll happen is is I'll name a new
giveaway winner when I post that gravity
falls Rick and Morty Easter Egg video in
a couple days but all you have to do to
enter that to just be a subscriber leave
a comment about Rick and Morty on the
video you can click here for all my
season 3 videos and you can click here
for my season 4 predictions video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome Happy Holidays
[Music]
[Applause]